[Music]
you're saying that you're that you're on
the show right now cuz a couple of days
ago
marked the 20th anniversary of our show
going on the air you I think were the
second or third writer hired you were
one of the original on the original
writing original stuff and II was
already there right and I think there
was like four or five already but I was
yeah
September 13th I remember we went on the
air 1993 and you were there at summer
meal yeah we had ordered like in June or
July yeah we started putting together we
had no time no one knew who the hell I
was was thirty years old I had just
turned 30 I was 29 when I auditioned and
I was like I can do this and for like
two years America was like no you can
but I found we found this picture
earlier of the first time this is the
day we went on the air right that's
right there's me I'm such a sweet young
girl and there's Andy nathan Reynolds
Bob over there yeah and there you are
horse and and look he's there is Louie
and Dino Stan metropolis marshmallow and
then of course the famous Robert Smigel
over my shoulder and there and Bob
Odenkirk now on Breaking Bad right who's
gonna be here on Monday yeah it's just
so just looking at that and I was
noticing in this picture everyone's
looking at the camera except you you're
looking away you're looking to a better
future than the rest of us
even then you knew I've got other what
do you remember like from the whole I I
mean I was a huge learning experience
and I learned a lot from you because
yeah they kept trying to take the show
away yes it was hard and every Friday we
would all call our agents ago I don't
think we're gonna keep going and you
would roll up your sleeves and you know
get on the phone with NBC and say give
me like three more days and you just
stuck to it it was so much pressure
yeah but you're a good boss and you were
very in class getting into it a few
times yeah we've got a few fights yes we
kind of could bully you you were like
you know like I had one bit for the
actual items that sort of we did we did
a version of that thing that they do on
the current incarnation of The Tonight
Show where they hold up ads that are
real and we used to make up fake one
this one's an act really quick I can't
believe they made this but obviously we
made it we had major favor they were
incredibly insanely wrong and in prefer
exactly so I wrote one and you didn't
want to do it and I was like you're an
[ __ ] like I got a Matthew and then
you did it you're like all right I'll do
it and you man what it was they do it
was for like point like an TV Guide
they'll have like ads for rare coins you
can send away for us and I said these
coins are so old you could buy slaves
with them I want to do that and I was a
huge [ __ ]
so you did it I'm standing like by the
cameras and you did it and just boom and
I watched you just bravely take a boo
that belonged to me yeah with a lot of
courage you had a lot of courage and and
then there was one time where you yelled
at you and I just yelled you in front of
everybody and then I cried like Jan
Brady and ran out of the room I cried
and ran out of the room and then you
called me at home and you said listen
I'm glad you feel like you can express
dissent and you know I want you to be
able to say if you disagree and we're
okay when we go back to work the more
you were really cool you're very nice so
I appreciated that and I was wrong you
know 25 years old yeah was doing early I
should have fired